we had big news today Sydney Powell
pleads guilty over efforts to overturn
Trump's loss in Georgia and agrees to
cooperate now I'm seeing uh a lot of uh
Trump supporters are like wow she she
got a great deal all the felonies Dro
just a handful of misdemeanors now talk
about an amazing plea and I'm like no
they got what they wanted they wanted
the headline Sydney pal pleads guilty
and they got it cuz all anyone thinks
they don't think about the minutia of
the court case they're not thinking
about the individual charges they don't
even know what she was charged with all
they know is she's an insurrectionist
and she just admitted it now she's going
to testify likely against Donald Trump
so I'm curious what you guys think as to
where this ends up going but I certainly
do think they will begin to file their
14th Amendment removal takedowns of
trump or whatever now that this is
in yeah that's pretty likely I mean I
think it's sad to see this play out I
think that's my overwhelming uh reaction
to this I hate to make any accusations
before we actually hear her testimony
right like we don't know what's going to
happen um and I can't imagine being in
the position the thing is she apologized
already to the state yeah which is ter
she getting six years of probation I
think that's it yeah very unlikely she's
not testifying so she is testifying for
and she will testify against the other
defendants the thing that I am so
curious about and it's it's not that I
don't want to make excuses for anything
like that but when the federal
government decides to pursue you it is
so costly this is Georgia uh this is
Georgia but it's backed by the entire
state right like any State litigation
any long-term litigation and having to
turn over documents and having to turn
over emails I mean I don't think it's
right I would have preferred to see her
not uh take a plea but I think this
proves she's a grifter I think this
proves she is a grifter because you know
I was talking about it earlier I could
not imagine genuinely believing a thing
right imagine if they came to you and
said do you believe in the the the
vision of the founding fathers yes okay
we are going to destroy your life unless
you stand before the the court and the
people and tell them you don't believe
these things most people are going to be
like no like are you like some a lot of
people would say yes they'll be like
I'll do anything you say please but
those are people who never actually
cared in the first place anyone who
stands up on stage the microphone and
says I believe with the founding fathers
believed and blah blah blah in the
Constitution and then immediately he
like I'll I'll say anything you want to
say grifter well I will say this though
one thing this is the AP and we are
relying on this entire conversation from
a headline from the media that very
people that we don't trust do we trust
that they're giving us the whole story
number one and now look I'm not
defending anything that's going on I
want to give a different perspective I
go on Twitter spaces all the time I
listen to the j6 I listen to the people
that are being attacked by a weaponized
government and I will say there was one
j6 person in particular I'm not going to
name that person's name but the
government leaked information
purposefully to make it seem like that
j6 defendant was talking to the
government so that all of us the people
that were in his family would turn on
him yes but there is a video possible
huh there's video from the courtroom
where she's saying yes yes yes attacking
Donald Trump no no no they say will you
you you're pleading guilty yes and and
your your sentence will be you know you
you've agreed to something like you
you've agreed to allow us access to
certain information and documents yes oh
sure you will testify this person also
gave some information but the fact of
the matter is could it be that this is a
duality they want to use her not only to
attack Donald Trump but they want to
turn every friend of her against her is
that possibility she had to agree to it
yeah true but I mean when you're forced
with 14 felonies
whatever I hate to say it how many
people would for the right reason go
through 14 felonies it really it it
really it really depends and I it
depends on your level of conviction so
I'll just giving a different perspective
not defending are you Christian yes uh
Ashley you're CHR I'm Jewish you're
Jewish okay uh and you're obviously
Christian right Serge are you Christian
uh yeah Protestant if you were brought
before a court and they said we are
going to use the full weight of the
state government we will lock you up for
decades unless you renounce Jesus Christ
in a courtroom would you do it I want to
hope that I would do the right thing you
have to denounce his name apologize for
ever ever having believed in him and
tell everyone how you know longer
believe it and you never believed it in
fact would you do it I don't think I
could do it so that my my point is
obviously your faith in Christ is Leaps
and Bounds above politics correct but
I'm just using that as The Benchmark of
where does someone stand when they're
willing to say I don't actually believe
a thing if it benefits them in some
other way and again I'm not trying to
compare them directly I'm trying to
actually contrast them and say you can
understand most people who believe in
who are religious and like Ashley in
your instance like reject God and
denounce your your faith uh most people
would not do that and then you go way
down to the political realm which is
very far from from Faith but it's a
question of how much conviction a person
has in what they're saying I think
anybody who is willing to get up on
stage for months and Proclaim something
asserting its truth and then when it
comes to the court the opportunity to
get this evidence on the record in front
of a jury in front of people on TV says
I plead guilty just you know that shows
that they were grifting the whole time
well that compelled speech but again the
punishments against her are so severe
the compelled speech is the most
important aspect to them in my opinion
and we see this throughout everything it
characterizes everything from the left
including big Tac even when Twitter was
Banning people or suspending people from
tweets for tweets they the most
important part of that was they made you
admit you did something wrong they made
you admit that this tweet was
transphobic this tweet was this that
compelled speech aspect is very very
important to them so they're going to do
whatever they need to do to get it from
you're right I mean the biggest thing is
they have you know Trump affiliate
pleads guilty that's that's you know
second to Trump's mug shot itself this
these are these big uh visual targets
they're trying to hit and this is what I
think conservatives don't get
conservatives are playing a logic game
and Democrats and Liberals are playing
an emotions game for sure and so I do
think instantly every like conservative
or anti-work person was like we know
that's how no no no no people are saying
like it doesn't matter because the
paperwork didn't say this and Sydney
didn't say that I'm like no no you don't
understand how this works give it two or
three weeks the Wikipedia page for this
will say Donald Trump Sydney pow like
they the the media will manufacture The
Narrative now that they've been given
the seat the first sideline will say
Sydney pow pleads guilty over efforts to
overturn Trump's loss in Georgia and
agrees to cooperate that's the headline
number one headline number two will come
from a liberal publication that will say
something like Sydney Powell admits
Donald Trump was attempting to overturn
election pleads guilty then a few weeks
later you'll get Trump uh like new
statements from cine Powell suggest
Trump instructed her to attempt to
overthrow the the the government and
then just just all will be based off
each other and exaggerations of the last
give it one year and the story maped
will be in in 2020 Donald Trump
instructed Sydney Powell to sneak into
an office and destroy a b like it'll
just make it up it'll be it'll be the
most absurd thing ever and so what they
needed was the seed and the seed was her
saying guilty I'm guilty now they have
it I mean and that's that's probably why
they would push so hard that I'm not
saying she's doing anything right I'm I
think you're right there is a level of
like you want everyone to stand by their
convictions and you're seeing this from
other you know people who are associated
with Trump to tremendous cost to
themselves both financially and
personally I mean one of the challenges
with any kind of uh intense
investigation is the fact that they just
consume your life right if they ask you
to turn over every email that you ever
sent from whatever email address for the
past four years I mean that's thousands
and thousands and thousands and
thousands of different types of
documents you have to go through it's
not that she should have taken the plea
but it's not to say that this is the
government fighting Fair she's still in
prison she's still going to be in prison
metaphorically speaking she I mean this
is worse than going to jail in my
opinion having to live this way for her
having to sell out and testify and
cooperate with these horrible people
this is worse than jail but I think in
prison I think it's going to have a
massive impact on the other defendants
mhm mhm it's not even if she it will
testify imagine you awaiting your trial
and they come to you and they say like
she's agreed to testify against you
you're we're not going to give you a
deal what's what happens next is they go
to the next guy like Chase bro or
whatever and they're going to say she
got six years probation we're going to
give you one year in jail that's the
best offer you'll get they'll be like
but but what why that's that's crazier
than what she got like yeah because
she's testifying against you that's a
worst prison in living to know that you
sold out those people and everyone's
still gonna hate you because they're
still G to make these headines about you
meanwhile a a celebrity makeup uh uh
producer whatever her name is uh Huda
Huda Huda something no Huda I can't
remember her last name but she's the
Iranian line is Huda Beauty she has
posted videos saying she would rather
have her business destroyed than sell to
Israelis like I'm I'm paraphrasing she
said she doesn't want their blood Money
the conviction on the left is palpable
yeah she goes on her platform to all of
her followers however many millions and
crying saying she sides with Palestine
and then people are like hey Israelis
like your Israelis like your products
too and go I don't want your blood money
but you're right think about the
convictions you're right they do have
more conviction and they have more coni
despite them being anti- capitalist
they're better capitalists than us
because they vote with their dollars
better than we do they have that
conviction but it could also just be
components of the deep state that I
actually no uh my my point is when it
comes to the woke left in general the
machine supports you it's easier to side
with the machine in this instance the
the machine was against Nea she sides
with the machine however in the instance
of Hamas the machine is not in favor of
what the left is supporting and they so
supporting It Anyway which proves the
point there they they are many of these
people have convictions that they will
not let go and they will stand before
the world and say don't buy my product I
will sacrifice everything for what I
believe in and on the right you get
grifters but I think this not all of
them but you know this is tantamount to
president Trump though we're seeing
indictment after indictment we're seeing
the weaponization
and look I I want to make it clear about
my neutrality but the fact of the matter
is look at what's working on people like
this article right here clearly they
found the blueprint that if they charge
you with X Y and Z they can get you to
plead guilty to lower whatever charges
they did against you and then they're
going to use that same blueprint against
everybody else what if they're doing
these indictments to try to get
president Trump to drop out and if he
did they would have the blueprint for
the future of what to do to every other
presidential opponent from here on out
it's not just presidential opponents
though this is a total weaponized doj
and the problem with this law fair is
they're showing us that they can
weaponize any law against any of us most
of us they could weaponize a law against
us if they wanted to I mean the New York
attorney general is sort of famous for
this Laticia James she goes after
project baratos goes after all kinds of
people and part of it again like I'm
saying is the leadup to the case before
you even get into court all the demands
that are placed on you to turn over
documents or to be compliant or whatever
else it's crazy and I think that's the
stuff that we don't see because we only
seen it when it gets to the headlines
and that's not completely unreasonable
the stuff is very hard to follow it's
happening behind closed doors for the
most part uh but I think this idea I
think your neutrality is interesting and
great because if it could happen for
Trump who is such a public figure think
about who it's happening for who we
don't know about or smaller
organizations or smaller candidates I
mean any anyone could then be brought up
under the same charges that's how
precedent
works that's absolutely right and they
didn't care all those years he was
operating in New York they didn't care
now all of a sudden they care but that's
that's how law fair works they're
they're they're completely lying about
everything about Trump these these these
court cases the lawsuits it's all
nonsense but it's for strategic PR it's
a weaponized doj I mean that's what
you're talking about and I just think
ultimately because uh because all legal
court cases there's so much back and
forth right they're in court they're out
of court they Chang this charge they
they reach whatever it is hard to keep
the focus of the American people and
that's why the flashy headline is the
biggest weapon right now thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net